Assuming a minimal mutual willingness to
be any contact and to receive
communications,
we may say that the greater the
communicated congruence of experience,
awareness and behavior on the part of
one individual,
the more the ensuing relationship will
involve a tendency towards reciprocal
communication with the same qualities,
mutually accurate understanding of the
communications.
It probed psychological adjustment and
functioning in both parties and mutual
satisfaction in the relationship.
Pretty good hypotheses.
So basically what he's saying is that,
okay,
if we're communicating and I tell you
what's actually going on with me the
best I possibly can and try to get rid
of all of the motives that have nothing
to do with communication,
then that's going to work out quite
nicely in the long run.
It's gonna work out for both of us and
for the relationship.
So like it's good.
It's an interesting hypothesis.
I can tell you that people don't do
this.
You know,
I showed you that Gottman,
I don't know how many of you looked at
that blame the Godman studies on marital
satisfaction.
Right?
But I thought that was really
interesting because I've seen people
like that lots of times,
you know,
they're on the surface,
everything's fine,
but well sometimes the tension is so
high,
you can hardly even stand to be in the
room with the people you know,
because you,
you can just add,
add,
add an embodied level,
you're mirroring the distress,
you know,
we get a pit in your stomach,
it's hard to breathe and you just know.
It's probably smell,
I think is what it's trans as what it's
communicated by,
you know,
smell affects us and all sorts of ways
we don't understand.
So here,
here's an example.
Women like the smell of tee shirts that
men wore if the men are symmetrical
better than if the men aren't
symmetrical.
So that's a good example of how smell
affects you.
It affects you in lots of ways.
So anyways.
MMM.
What godman observed was that basically
that the capitals that weren't getting
along,
we're just lying to each other all the
time.
Right?
Because they were pretending that
everything was all right.
When in fact nothing was all right at
all.
Their bodies were going haywire.
That's a technical term haywire.
So it was way too stressful for them.
And you,
you might say,
well,
why is that bad?
Why shouldn't you be like that?
Because that's a good question.
Well,
one is if your stress responses are to
elevated,
we know what happens.
That's the general I stress response.
Your cortisol levels go up and then well
then you age the fast.
So if you want to age fast,
that's a very good way of doing it.
But if that's not your goal,
your goal is peace and harmony.
Then pretending that everything's all
right without communicating isn't going
to work.
And so the couples aren't saying things
like
there's something about the way we're
talking,
it's making me extremely nervous,
you know?
And then actually tried to figure that
out.
It's like,
I wouldn't say,
well,
you're making me nervous because,
maybe you are,
but maybe not.
Maybe I'm just a nervous type.
God only knows.
Let's see if we can sort this out.
Or maybe I'm nervous about something
else completely.
You know,
maybe I'm nervous about women.
So there's lots of digging to do.
Okay.
So you can think about that and think,
well,
is that a reasonable proposition now?
Okay,
you can try this.
This is an excellent,
this is,
I'm not going to t tell you many
specific psychological exercises,
but this is a really good one.
It's hard to,
okay,
Rio communicational curves and the
evaluative tendency avoided when we
listen with understanding.
So the evaluated Roger's theory is,
is difficult to understand with regards
to the relationship between the
evaluation and unconditional positive
regard because he tends to speak as if
the valuation is bad.
But really what he means is hierarchical
elevate evaluation,
which is you're worse than me or I'm
better than you.
It's like those things might even be
true in any given case,
but they're not relevant to what we're
doing.
Right?
We're trying to do something,
I'll do it than that.
So when that creeps in,
I think of that as dominance,
hierarchy,
maneuvering,
not Africans all the time.
When people are talking,
you know,
they're just maneuvering around in a
dominance hierarchy.
They're not trying to communicate.
So that's the evaluative tendency.
What does this mean?
It means to see the expressed idea.
And attitude from the other person's
point of view to sense how it feels to
him to achieve his frame of reference in
regard to the thing he is talking about
stated so briefly.
This may sound absurdly simple,
but it is not.
It's an approach which we have found
extremely potent in the field of
psychotherapy.
It's the most effective agent we know
for altering the basic personality
structure of an individual and improving
his relationships and his communications
with others.
That's a quite the statement.
You know
the most effective agent we know for
altering the basic personality structure
of an individual.
If I can listen to what he tells me,
if I can understand how it seems to him,
if I can see it's personal meaning for
him,
if I can sense the emotional flavor
which it has for him,
then I will be releasing potent forces
of change in him.
If I can really understand how he hates
his father or the university or
columnists,
if I can catch the flavor of this sphere
of insanity or his fear of atom bombs or
of Russia,
it will be of the greatest help to him
in altering those very hatreds and fears
and in establishing realistic and
harmonious relationships with the very
people and situations towards which he
has felt hatred and fear.
We know from our research,
by the way,
Rogers was one of the first clinicians
who empirically evaluated the outcome of
psychotherapy and so he actually more or
less established the idea that therapy
outcomes should be measured
scientifically.
And,
and in doing that,
he,
in some sense,
he set down one element of the standards
by which modern clinical psychologists
are actually trained in practice because
the modern clinical psychologist is a
scientist practitioner.
So the idea is that you should be
trained as a researcher and as a
practitioner and that's quite unique.
Doctors,
medical doctors for example,
are not trained that way.
Although you could make a very strong
case that they should be.
We know from our research that such
empathic understanding,
understanding with a person,
not about him.
It's such an effective approach that it
can bring about major changes in
personality.
Now,
some of you may be feeling that you
listen well to people and that you've
never seen such results.
The chances are very great indeed that
you're listening has not been of the
type I have described.
Fortunately,
I can suggest a little laboratory
experiment,
which you could try to test the quality
of your understand.
The next time you get into an argument
with your wife or your friend or with a
small group of friends to stop the
discussion for a moment and for an
experiment institute this rule.
Each person can only speak up for
himself once he has first restated the
ideas and feelings of the previous
speaker accurately and to that speaker
satisfaction.
Now,
that's the annoying part,
right?
Because if you're in an argument,
you're going to use all sorts of
rhetorical devices in order to win.
One of the most obvious of those
rhetorical devices is that you make your
case.
And I only half listen cause I'm
formulating what I'm going to say to you
next.
And then I pro I impose a bias in my
processing of your argument.
And so that what I address when I talked
to you is the sort of argument that
you'd make if you were weak and stupid
and contemptible and then I go after
that and that's basically a straw man
approach,
right?
I take your,
I take your position and I try to make
it into the scrawny as little ratty ass
thing I can possibly manage illustrating
that it needs to be rubbed out and then
I'd rub it out.
It's like the rigid approaches are
actually exactly the officer.